my great grandfather he said it best he
said life is on the wire
and everything else is just waiting for
our family it's in the literal sense
life is on the wire that is where we
feel alive the lenders are wire walkers
is this it this is all you do
professionally today i was gonna go off
to college to become a pediatrician but
i always had this passion
of walking a wire somebody was born in a
walenda family how soon am i getting on
the wire
as soon as you can stand up in fact
before my children could even stand up
i was holding them up walking on a wire
two feet off the ground did your mom
ever wire walk with being pregnant with
you or no she did
six months pregnant and she was still
walking the wire with me what you go
through that balancing pole weighs 45
pounds it's not just stable it's moving
the entire time
so the amount of forearm strength is
fairly overwhelming we talk about
chicago
times square niagara falls dennis
volcano nick
your margin for error is worst in golf
how do you stay sane on that road if you
fall it's over
i think our family has just turned that
fear into respect i mean i'll spend 68
hours a day on the wire often five six
days a week
we're risking our life with our passions
it's truly a battle a battle of the mind
leading up to this but once i get onto
that wire
all that goes away you guys call it the
pyramid walk and there was an
accident how were you able to recover
from that single event that happened to
your family
that was when my worst nightmare became
a reality it got to the point where i
told my wife and i said i'm done
i'm not getting back on the wire ever
again i'm done
you know in a time where a lot of people
are dealing with anxiety and panic
attack and trying to manage your fear
and all this imagination that you lose
control over and
you know you think about what what if
this happens and what if that happens
and what if this happens
my guest today may help you with that
because my guest today is nick wallande
let me tell you what nick wallanda does
uh he's a seven generation wire walker
these are folks that walk
on wire since 1780s they've been doing
this
he holds 17 various guinness book of
world records let me kind of give you an
idea what these
crazy records are he's the first man
ever to walk across
niagara falls yes i've been there before
it's crazy wind
he walked across niagara falls he walked
across chicago times square and
recently in march 4th of 2020 he walked
across
a volcano with that being said nick
thank you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
thanks for having me on first of all you
know
i was telling you earlier when i spoke
to robert kennedy one of the things i
was very curious about was
the lineage in his family and what they
talked about at night
and what were the questions and how did
they get people to get mentally so
strong
and in one interview i think in the book
total recall arnold schwarzenegger talks
about the fact he met the kennedys
and he asked me to say so hey john tell
me what's your favorite color
and his answer was we like the color red
he says no but what's your color he says
no we like red he says
the kennedy seemed so united when i was
around them
when i read and study your family i mean
how does a family get folks to believe
for seven generations that we're all
going to be wire walkers so
if we can go back to where that
tradition the values and principles
who is the original founder that started
this tradition
take us from there and then we'll go to
all the different experiences that
you've had
absolutely so my family history dates
back to the 1780s
so well over 200 years my family has
been wire walking
my great-grandfather is the one that
really made our family famous he brought
our family from germany
originally bohemia in the 1780s into
germany and brought our family over to
the united states
from germany in 1928 in fact he was
actually performing and they were
headlining on a show in havana cuba
and they were making headlines around
the world for doing these amazing
pyramids on the wire
and john ringling the founder of
ringling brothers barnum bailey circus
heard
that he needed to see this amazing wire
troop so he made his way over
to cuba on a ship got off went to see
the show
and that evening my grandparents were
great grandparents were getting ready to
get on the wire to perform
and as they got ready to perform the
show owner in cuba came up to them and
said this evening we're giving you the
night off
and my family sort of looked at
themselves and scratched their heads and
said this doesn't add up we're
headliners we're featured here
the audience this is a full house to see
us why are you giving us the night off
well the reason he was giving the night
off was because john ringling was in the
audience and he knew he was going to
lose this amazing performance group
to the united states and ringling
brothers circus but john ringling being
an astute businessman snuck in
the next day saw my family perform and
sign him to come over to the united
states to perform
on ringling brothers borrowing bailly
circus so they made their way over the
united states 1928
the the net the safety net that they had
used was lost in shipping
and they thought this is our debut in
the u.s there's no way we can avoid this
we've just got to go on without a safety
net
and the story is told that they were set
up so high
in madison square garden for that
opening night that john ringling came
into the arena
hours before the show and said there's
absolutely no way i'm going to let them
perform that high
and made them lower the rigging some but
the story goes that they got on the wire
and they did this amazing performance of
heart stopping feats and immediately
afterwards the audience went crazy
and they were whistling and screaming
and foot stomping but my family was
scared to death
because whistling and screaming and foot
stomping was the same as being booed off
the stage back in that time in europe
so they thought they were horrible they
were horrendous they were failures and
and that they were going to get kicked
out of the country
but little did they realize the
ringmaster ran to the door and called
them back to the arena where they
received a 15-minute standing ovation
for their first performance in the in
the old garden uh so that's sort of the
legacy that i inherited but
my great-grandfather uh you know he said
it best he said life is on the wire
and everything else is just waiting and
for i think everybody in the world
especially with this virus we're facing
we're all on a wire
but for our family it's in the literal
sense life is on the wire that is where
we feel alive
my mom was six months pregnant and still
walking the wire that's crazy
i started walking a wire when i was 18
months old
it is truly life to us it is not a a
decision it is not a choice
it is it is truly who we are like the
kennedys like red
the wallenders are wire walkers now now
but but that part like when you
so if i'm if i'm in your house and had a
camera because your grandfather died in
78 at the age of 73 with the
a horrific event that by the way before
even doing the interview with you i've
seen that video god knows how many times
in puerto rico when that event took
place
yes and he's doing a walk and and i
won't show the video but i'm sure the
viewers are going to see it i don't want
to show while you and i are talking
so he he dies in 78 when he's doing this
stunt walking across
two waterfront hotels i think it's like
a not a big distance that he went across
but he did it and he falls and
hits the car and uh uh dead on arrival
to the hospital
you're born a year later so you never
really had a chance to spend time with
him because i think you're a 79 baby and
he passed away in 78.
but correct what what mindsets from your
grandfather and your family was passed
down to like what stories have you heard
about how he was
at the dinner table what are the family
talking about they talked about he that
he was just an amazing man of
inspiration he was a very driven
individual a lot of his traits were
passed on to me
it's interesting there are 17 of us that
still walk the wire to this day
but i have a different drive than the
rest you've heard of nick wallenda
and and i would say the reason is is
because of that drive i've had the drive
to walk across the grand canyon
for instance i've had the drive to
continue to to push you know walking
across niagara falls took changing two
laws in two countries that were over 100
years old
that was just to get permission to do
the walk so that process
takes a lot of tenacity and and a lot of
grit and
uh that is something that he certainly
passed on to me my parents say it's so
interesting how
within a nine-month span of his death i
was born and there are so many
similarities and i never met him
but i will tell you that growing up i
was always told of these stories on how
he was always willing to push the limits
how
he was always willing to step out of his
comfort zone how he would
he would return to the wire 1962 fatal
accident two family members killed one
paralyzed in detroit michigan
my great grandfather not only was he
injured severely but he snuck out of the
hospital against the doctor's orders
just to get back on the wire the
following day
because he had that drive and there are
so many parallels
between his life and mine and and by the
way crazy data is he was born i think
january 2
1st and you're born january 24th you
guys are three days apart
that's correct i know you're i know
you're a christian man you probably
don't even look at the data matching all
that other stuff but
for me my entire life i ask people about
birthdays and it's amazing how you guys
have a similar personality
and your birthday is three days apart so
you know
when i see the video i've seen it
multiple times
i have to tell you i i can't help myself
but my stomach
gets it gets uncomfortable we had
one of our guys just walked in here
before doing the interview
and he watched a couple of videos and he
has vertigo
and he lost it right there he's like i
can't even watch this like you have to
step away
how often like when's the last time you
saw the video of you
your grandfather in puerto rico and when
people want to play it for you do you
look away or are you comfortable seeing
that one
i would tell you that that is a video
that i've seen hundreds of times in fact
i had a series on the discovery channel
and it was really the science and
engineering behind what we do and in
that series i had the honor of
recreating that walk that he fell and
lost his life from and there
again many parallels in fact he was he
was on the sidewalk and was interviewed
by a reporter moments before he went up
to the wire
i was interviewed by that exact same
reporter on that same sidewalk moments
before i went up on the wire
so so many parallels but during that
series we did a bunch of research
and we had a bunch of geriatric
specialist doctors watch that video in
slow motion over and over again
and what we've always were told is that
the reality of why he lost his life was
because that wire was rigged
improperly and and we know that for sure
in fact the way it was stabilized was
improper rather than that wire being
rock solid which what he was was what he
was accustomed to
it actually moved quite a bit because of
those stabilizer ropes that were coming
off of it
and uh he was trained and prepared for
any stable wire but the reality was at
73 years old
your heart isn't prepared to take the
amount of adrenaline in the adrenaline
rush that he would have gotten
from an unstable wire and they say that
he didn't notice that was unstable in
fact
in fact my father was supposed to be
there to rig it as well as my uncle and
they both had previous engagements
actually my dad had to stay home because
my mom had just had a miscarriage and he
was there with her
so he had a couple other guys on his
crew set it up and they they took a
couple shortcuts
and in the end what that did was it
caused his adrenaline to go up to the
point where
we believe he went into cardiac arrest
went down to the wire
which is what we're all trained to do
and we'll talk about the accident in
2017 where i did just that
he went down to the wire to hold on and
at that point in cardiac arrest
he couldn't hold on and that's in the
end what caused him to lose his life it
wasn't the wind
it wasn't a lack of balance it was
actually we believe it was
an unstable wire and then of course the
fact that he couldn't
take that amount of blood pressure into
his heart so so let me ask you
do you do this professionally yourself
or do you do anything else is this
it this is all you do professionally
today so for most of my career this is
what i've done professionally i will
tell you that there was a lot of back
and forth early on in my in
in my younger years in fact my
great-grandfather in his book that he
wrote in the 70s he said
in the circus world and the circus world
is my background one day you eat the
chicken and the next day you eat the
feathers
and that was very true for me growing up
we went through a lot of setbacks my mom
wrote a book in the mid to late 80s
called the last of the wallendas
because she didn't think there was a
future in the industry so there was a
time where i worked in a restaurant
where my parents really pushed me off
and wanted me to go to college and do
something different
i was accepted at a university and i was
going to go off to college to become a
pediatrician
was sort of my thoughts it was another
dream of mine but i always had this
passion
of walking a wire so to answer your
question it is my main source of income
i do run
other businesses locally in florida
where i live got it i know you're in
tallahassee
yourself and i got a couple offers in
tallahassee myself as well i know the
area is a very different kind of a
florida than a south beach florida
but uh you know so you run other
businesses out of the 17 you said we
have 17 family members today
who still uh wire walk how many of them
do it for the purpose of entertainment
uh how many of them doing as a purpose
of a showman like i'm going up there and
i'm doing a show and other people are
watching it
what's the breakdown between the 17 yeah
i would tell you that
all 17 do it with the intent and the the
aspirations of being able to support
their family and
as a business however because the circus
world has changed so much and that is
their primary source of income
they have had to take other on other
occupations meanwhile so
all of them though including my mother
we just actually did a walk
between two skyscrapers in tampa tampa
bay at the hard rock casino where
my mom who's 67 years old got on a wire
walked out to the middle
150 feet up no safety devices sat down i
stepped over her
and we walked into opposite ends so it
it's similar to telling tiger woods to
put down the golf club because he's
retired from the pga or the pga senior
tour at one point
he's still going to golf it's his
passion it's what he loves doing in fact
that's what defines tiger woods in a lot
of senses
that's the same with wire walking and
for our family it is very hard to put
down the balancing pole if you will
and move on because we're so passionate
about it yeah i mean it's
it's it's obviously felt so how soon how
early on if i'm in the if i'm a wallanda
by the way can you pronounce the name my
accent is hurting me from pronouncing
your property
it's wallenda wallenda wallenda yes sir
wallenda okay i'm going to get it right
excuse my assyrian and persian accent
here wallenda so
if i'm in your family if i'm born in
your family if somebody is born in a
walenda family
how soon am i getting on the wire as
soon as you can stand up
in fact before my children could even
stand up
i was holding them up walking on a wire
two feet off the ground it is it's
amazing my mom
tells the story of when i was a child
and the first time that she grabbed my
hand and helped me onto the wire
and it was in our backyard to this day
in my backyard i have 15 acres i have a
wire that's 700 feet long i have one
that
50 feet long all different heights and
just for training of course
and in preparing for these events that i
take on but from a young age i saw my
parents doing this and how passionate
they were about it how much they enjoyed
it and i wanted to be a part of it
so i would reach up to them just like a
child who sees another kid on a swing
set
he goes up or he sees his father with a
hammer driving a nail he grabs that
hammer well
for my family that was wire walking so
my mom said from from about 18 months
old the first time she put me on the
wire
she said it was fascinating the fact
that i knew exactly how to put my feet
on the wire as though it was in my dna
it was in my nature
she said it was mind-boggling she said
that the first time i got on a bicycle
on a wire
there was no assistance whatsoever i got
on that bicycle and i rode from one side
to the other
mind you low you know about two feet off
the ground but no help whatsoever and i
wrote across
what was awesome is i have a nephew and
uh he's about
he's about nine now but when he was four
years old he came to visit me and he was
in my backyard
and he wanted to get on the wire and i
grabbed his hand and i get goosebumps
telling you this story but it was the
same exact thing
i put him on the wire and it was as
though it was second nature he was in
his blood
he knew how to place his feet and has
that drive in fact
at this point he's nine years old and he
is an awesome wire walker and we're
working on maybe
breaking a world record or allowing him
to break a world record obviously
considering all safety issues with
miners etc but he'll be able to set on
his own world record at nine years old
because he's so good on the wire
oh cool did your mom ever wire walk with
being pregnant with you or no
she did six months pregnant and she was
still walking the wire with me so
honestly long longer than i better go or
in a backyard like is it short
nope no so so circus women as a whole
are extremely fit and and my mom didn't
even show that she was pregnant barely
showed at six months
she barely had a bump in her belly so
she walked the wire
performing in front of an audience until
she was six months pregnant with me
man that's just by the way how much of
it is when you're saying you know hey
you you see what your parents are doing
if your dad hits a hammer you want to go
hit the hammer
how much of it is i want to do what that
is doing how much of it is
hey nick get on that wire how much of it
is pushing you to get on that wire
you know in the circus industry as a
whole it was very much
you better get on that wiring practice
that's how you're going to pay your
bills my mom is the wallenda my dad
married into it at 18. he's got an
amazing family six siblings that are all
engineers two of them are in fact head
engineers at nasa
that's just how brilliant his family is
so he has a different mindset
than the history of my family and the
way i was raised so my dad was opposite
my dad
if anything pushed me away from it and
said don't get into this man it's
addictive
you'll fall in love with it but you got
to be able to support a family and we're
struggling to do so
so it was actually just the opposite
with me is they didn't want me to do it
yet
it was it was my passion it was what i
love doing and i i can't imagine not
doing it
did you catch yourself wanting to know
more about your grandpa constantly how
was he like
this what do you do here you want to
watch all the videos read all the
articles learn everything about the guy
absolutely and i don't
really know why i mean obviously he's
been my inspiration i've looked up to
him
he is an incredible was an incredible
role model uh but there is a fascination
that i have with him and people often
ask me you know 10 quick questions and
who would you want to meet if you could
meet anyone in the world it would be my
great grandfather i mean there is
there is there would be no one more uh
incredible at least for me opportunity
in the world than to spend time with my
great-grandfather and tell stories
and truly everything i do is really to
shine light on him he's the one who
paved the road
to get to where i am and that's why i
walk over these crazy places
always trying to honor and respect him
that's what's so uh uh
beautiful about the way you talk about
him man it's you know you've been able
to do stuff that he was never able to do
uh during your time but every time it's
so much about honoring him
lifting him up and lifting god up and
the way you go about doing
it everybody is rooting for you to do it
because indirectly you're doing it for
you and you're doing it for your grandpa
it's a beautiful thing to see but
let's talk about some of the stuff that
you've been able to do i mean
we talk about chicago times square you
know a niagara falls i know started up
with niagara falls and june 15 of 2012
then it's chicago then it's time square
dennis volcano
which one was the first official big one
you did in your eyes
where you say this is when people said
this guy's
to be doing stuff like his grandpa did
and doing big stuff in his life which
one was it for you
i would tell you it was in 2000 uh let's
see it was 2008
and i had an opportunity to uh break a
world record live on the today show
and it's one that's not not very very
much talked about but i
rode a bicycle on a wire 135 feet above
the streets of newark new jersey
for a distance of about 200 feet which
set two world records in fact
the record prior to that was about 40
feet so i tripled that record
uh both ways and actually almost five
times as far as length goes so
um that was the one that sort of
launched my career in a sense however i
would tell you
that after that walk i got off on the
other side
and and matt lauer said what are you
going to do next nick and i said i want
to be the first person to walk across
the grand canyon on a tightrope
and within six weeks i signed a contract
with nbc
to be the first person to walk across
the grand canyon and
you look at my timeline it doesn't match
up and the reason being was
about six months into that process all
the engineering was done the site was
was prepped uh the cable was purchased
we were ready to go
nbc fired the head of specials that
contracted me to do that
and when that happened my special went
out the door with him so we got a call
and said hey
sorry nick uh this ain't happening where
they told my managers
we're gonna take this off of our slate
and i remember the wind being knocked
out of my sails because here i thought
that this is what our family needed in
order to
be able to actually support stop eating
the feathers and start eating chicken
full time
and uh so i thought this was the big
break and again six months into that
literally three months from that special
happening live
it got pulled out from under me and i
remember just going back and thinking
and i often think to my great
grandfather like what would he do here i
just feel like giving up
i don't feel like carrying on and and i
always look to him for inspiration and
just like he got back on the wire after
that accident in 1962
the following day he continued on
against all odds and all these tragedies
i thought you know what my
great-grandfather would keep pushing and
i'm not going to give up
but i'm going to i'm going to kind of
change my direction a little bit and i
knew that niagara falls
a there was a lot more there's a lot
more business in that area that would be
able to help fund this because it was
going to cost
it ended up costing over a million
dollars to rig that wire to do this walk
and through that process i realized i
was going to have to change two laws one
in the united states over 100 years old
and one in canada
in order to get permission and i i felt
like if i can get the government behind
this and through that process
we can get a bunch of momentum behind us
then a
network will sign on and we can get a
bunch of sponsors and endorsements
that'll actually cover the cost
and in fact that's what happened after a
year of trying to get permission and
going through
senators governor cuomo signed
legislation giving me an exemption to
that 100 year old law to walk across
niagara falls
then i still had to go to canada and
that was another process that was a
nightmare but eventually got through
that
and through that process i got a tweet
from from good morning america
and abc and she said would you be
willing to come on our show and i said
of course
so i flew to new york city was on the
show and she said well you stay after
your interview
the president of of news division here
at abc would like to speak with you
and we sat down and they ended up
agreeing to cover the costs but what
people don't realize was that in the end
that walk over niagara falls cost me
thirty thousand over thirty thousand
dollars thirty to forty thousand dollars
out of my own pocket when i didn't have
it
in order to do that walk but i knew it
was an investment that would take me
into my future in fact
we had a gofundme that helped cover some
of those costs prior to back when that
was a brand new thing
prior to me taking that walk because the
network didn't cover all the costs
so so what was the 30 to 40 000 cost for
you
uh it was just an addition to the
rigging there was extra stuff that was
mandated on me in fact
about two weeks before that walk i was
walking over the inner harbor in
baltimore
another parallel of my great grandfather
he walked over that inner harbor
back in the 60s and i went back to
recreate it but again i always try to
honor him and do something unique so i
decided i was going to walk
from the land to a crane that was on a
barge so as i was walking that wire was
moving quite a bit
because of course in that harbor there's
there's waves smaller waves but enough
movement on a barge
that that that crane was moving about
three quarters the way up there was
about
30 000 people in attendance live and
good morning america was covering it
live
and i made my way up three quarters away
and one of my best friends was in a
basket at the top ready to take my
balancing pole
and i looked at him and i said hey chris
do you want to see 30 000 people scream
and he goes yeah because he knew exactly
what i was going to do somebody i grew
up with
and i acted like i was going to fall and
i slipped i did a fake slip on the wire
and thirty thousand and one people
screamed because it wasn't just the
thirty thousand in attendance
but the president of abc was watching
and what happened was before i got on
the wire
my manager had a a text from the
president of abc news
in all caps saying what was that and
that turned into a tale spin
of them saying we're not going to air
this so here i am again
this is two weeks from walking across
niagara falls abc says we're pulling the
plug on this and they're funding it
a long story short what it came down to
was we negotiated with him and they said
we'll allow him to do it but if he does
he has to wear a tether
so my biggest fear walking over niagara
falls was that tether because i'd never
worn one in my entire career
until until that day live on abc and my
concern was
is this going to trip me up my great
grandfather always taught that
safeties are a false sense of security
and the reason he said that was he had
an older brother that bounced
fell into a net bounced out and was
killed so even though you have a safety
device it makes your mind think oh
everything's fine i'll be okay i got a
safety device but the reality is it
isn't and if you can become
if you become complacent because you
have a net that's when you you can be in
grave danger
that that's that's what i mean a big
part of our audience are entrepreneurs
and business people
a big part of what you're saying right
now has to do with folks who start a
business and they have not plan b
plan you know c option all this other
stuff safety
and uh you hear all these great stories
of people not having it and they're the
ones that end up building a story that
the world ends up reading about and
here's one of them being you so so now
you end up doing niagara falls one of
the stats that i saw was you were
walking over 600 gallons
per second roaring over the horseshoe
falls
that history tells us many have fallen
in there
very few come out i mean the the the
wraith is it's a very small percentage
of people that survive
if they fall in there if you fall it's
over that we're not going to have this
interview
while you're going through niagara falls
for you 13 million people are watching
on abc
okay we're not talking thirty thousand
one
you know thirty thousand one people
every time 13 million people are
watching you
go through this how are you in your own
mind
stay insane and calm to know that you
can get through this
how do you do that part because you know
you watch basketball
you watch somebody shoot a three-pointer
and it hits the backboard
goes off the rim goes to the top drops
down like the
kwai leonard shot lasts you with the
toronto raptors and eventually goes in
they beat the
philadelphia 76ers right you can get
lucky with a three-pointer
you can get lucky with a hail mary throw
it up there the margin forever is not
this big like you can be three feet off
six feet off receiver's gonna catch it
nick your margin for error is
worse than golf how do you stay sane on
that rope
yeah it is you're absolutely right there
is very little margin for error
and and it is life and death but you
know i think it really
it dates back to my it goes back to my
family history this is life to me so
i'm able to stay calm in stressful
situations in life as a whole
generally if i see a car accident i'm
the first to get out if that car's on
fire
i'll walk right up to that car and pull
someone out in fact i've done that
before
i am just calm we'll talk about the
accident in 17 eventually
i stay cool and calm in very stressful
situations and i can attribute that
to the way i was raised to me being on
that wire there's something peaceful
about it
and the reason is all the troubles of
the world that we're dealing with
whether it be political or who knows
what's going on in our minds it could be
family it could be finances
that's all gone you know when i was
younger and worried about paying my
bills i would get on that wire and i can
promise you there was no thoughts of
paying my bills at that point
it was just this is freedom this is
peaceful and again
i think it's because i've done it so
long it is often very calming
often leading up to a walk i'll walk up
to the edge of that
that volcano months before
and i will look down and my heart will
start racing
when i walk up to the edge of that
volcano the knight that i'm going to
walk across and there's a wire there
my heart rate slows down why is that is
the
is the trust i said rope earlier on wire
this is a wire that you're walking
across most of these platforms
why what makes you calm about the seeing
the wire
what makes you calm about it because
i've been i've i've known and been
trained and it's been fed into my
mind over and over again that that wire
is a safety net
that as long as that wire is there i can
grab onto it and hold on
i also know that i have an incredible
team surrounding me and that wire is
rigged safely
so the rocks might crumble under my feet
as i'm standing on the edge of the grand
canyon however that wire is not coming
down
so if i'm standing on that wire i'm more
safe than i am on that rock
on the edge because that rock could give
way again but i have full confidence in
my team and the engineers
my father my uncle who oversee all my
rigging in the fact that that wire is
stable and safe
anybody in your family who walks wires
afraid of heights
no there aren't not that i have met uh
that are actually afraid of heights look
you're born with two fears they say the
fear of falling which is obviously
related to the fear of heights
and the fear of loud noises i think our
family has just turned that fear into
respect i talk about it in this latest
book but
basically i take what you would consider
fear
you walk up to a poisonous snake rather
than being fearful and turn around and
scream and run the best thing you can do
is stay calm and respect that snake and
slowly back away
and that's the same with us on that wire
when i get up to the edge i respect the
fact
that it's dangerous but that's why i
prepare so strongly leading
that walk that's why i go through the
rigorous training that i do that is
specifically detailed
and laid out like a map before every one
of my special events and big walks
now nick what is the biggest difference
for you between niagara falls between
chicago times square and the volcano
you know they're all very similar i try
not to compare any of them
uh and they were all stressful leading
up to it one way or another in fact it
seems like before every event there's
something that goes wrong
that just plays with my mind up until
the walk it's a mind game it is a battle
three days before that walk it is a
mental battle my
my my mind is trying to talk me out of
doing this
and uh and i have to continually counter
that negative with positive so when my
mind says
that volcano's gonna erupt i can say
well we've done studies and the odds of
that the chances of that happening are
slim to none i can say that you know
well the winds are gonna be strong well
you've walked in 90 mile an hour winds
so
it's truly a battle a battle of the mind
leading up to this but once i get onto
that wire
moments before all that goes away the
stress goes away it's it's sort of a
surreal moment
where i get into this zone in fact we
have set up a precedent that
if there's lightning if there's a reason
why i shouldn't get on that wire my dad
literally has to step in and physically
stop me from getting on that wire
because i get in such a mental state
that i'm going to walk across it whether
it be a hail storm a lightning storm
treacherous thunderstorm heavy winds it
doesn't matter i have made my mind up
and once i'm determined to do something
and i've proven it on and off the wire
i'm going to fulfill that that
determination in that drive
the volcano when you went through the
volcano some of the stuff i saw you
talking about it was a thousand feet
lava was two thousand degrees fahrenheit
one inch wire this is in nicaragua
march 4 2020 you know you went there a
day
you know before and there was no wire
and you're kind of looking on you you
could tell you were a little bit nervous
about it before before the wire was
being up
when you went up there are you feeling
the smoke are you feeling like what do
you feel when you're going through it
yeah so my training for the volcano
specifically was
a training because i knew i'd have to
wear an oxygen mask and that oxygen mask
could deprive i'm sorry a gas mask and
that gas mask could
deprive my oxygen levels down to about
75 percent most likely
so in training i trained with an oxygen
deprivation mask that would pull out
about 75
i was breathing only 30 oxygen while
training i train with heavy sandbags and
weights on
i train on a wire that is shorter
however i'll walk it about six or seven
times in fact that walk was 1800 feet
across
and i walked that i walked over a mile
on a cable in training
every single day for months leading up
to that i walked that entire length
forward and backwards i walked it with
my eyes closed
doing everything i could walked it in in
in heat suits
so that i was prepared for the heat so
that again when i get there i can look
at it and go yeah it might be 180
degrees or 150 degrees where i'm walking
at times with drafts of wind
but i know it's gonna pass and i know i
can withstand that i know i can walk
five times further i know i can walk
with
much less oxygen i know i can walk this
without being able to see
and all of that is the reason why i'm
able to once i get to that cable stay
calm
physically is there a exercise that's
the most
important exercise for you to do outside
of walking on a rope or wire
meaning is it legs is it shoulders
because when you're holding this you
need a little bit of shoulders you need
a little bit of biceps forearms
what keeps you in balance is it core
what's the main
uh exercise or body part you guys focus
on uh working out on
so it's it's very much core and arm
strength in fact i have an awesome
trainer and
just recently he's from the marines he
had one of his leg legs amputated in
fact and
he is a marine and and he i decided i
was going to teach him how to walk the
wire
and he's extremely fit and i remember
putting him on the wire and giving him
that balancing pull and he was just
blown away because he never picked it up
he trained me for these events but never
really spent time on the wire and he
picked it up
my family does all of the training on
the wire and then we have a trainer to
do the training off the wire and he
picked it up and he was like oh my gosh
this is insane i had no idea what you go
through that balancing pole weighs 45
pounds
it's not just stable it's moving the
entire time so the amount of forearm
strength is fairly overwhelming and
and again he was just blown away but
very much core
very much forearm and then i do a lot of
a lot of cardio training so what he
started doing with me which was unique
right before our time square walk was he
would have me run a run
half a mile and then get on the cable
and walk half a mile while i was still
out of breath he would have me stop
in fact part of my training is to do
push-ups on the wire
i can lay down and sit up on the wire i
can stand up i can
do squats on the wire so a lot of my
training was
is done on the wire even though you
would think how do you do a push-up on
the wire
how do you how do you do a squat on the
wire again that's all part of training
and all of that
knowing that hey i can walk this length
doing squats and push-ups i can sure as
heck do it without doing squats and
push-ups
we've spent a lot of time talking about
this stuff but your book facing fear
that just came out september 15 2020
and by the way you wrote it with a guy
that i'm very familiar with we met
multiple times years ago i think he's
written 11 books that's a new
new york time bestseller don yeager he's
a great writer he's done a lot of sports
stories and thomas nelson i'm very
familiar with them out of tennessee
today people are afraid there's a lot of
people that are
uh uh concerned they have anxiety they
have panic
you know they they tend to worry with
this pandemic
election protesting riots
fires there's so much going on
where you know the world is overwhelmed
a little bit right now
we haven't gone through this stuff and
it's all hitting at the same time is
there a formula
your family or yourself follows for you
to
not get overwhelmed or control your
anxiety or panic like when you are about
to have a panic attack or anxiety or get
nervous or afraid
what are you telling yourself what's the
formula where do you go to i'm curious
because
i think that's something a lot of people
can pick up from including myself
at any phase you're at yeah i think it
it very much comes down to the power of
our minds and and really the simplicity
the fact that we are in control of our
thoughts
we're in control of our minds our minds
are in control of us and we can
decide where we're gonna allow our mind
to go and and and
we can we can stop our mind when it
starts to go down that negative path
i am very very my family as a whole are
very careful on what we allow into our
minds
what we listen to what we watch on tv uh
the news that we listen to
in fact i choose to read all of my news
because then i can sort of control at
least
because you're right if we were to just
dwell on what's going on in our world
today
it's overwhelming for anyone i don't
care how powerful you are i don't care
if you've been a wallenda for 200 years
or not it is overwhelming
so my great-grandfather again always
taught us
in the way that we think and and passed
it on from generation to generation
where you allow your mind to go we have
to be in control
control of that and and and you know i
look i equate it to
simple things like an argument with my
wife if if i
get an argument with my wife immediately
my mind wants to i get really mad i'm
pissed off
my mind wants to go to places like 20
years of arguments with my wife rather
than
saying no i've had 20 amazing years with
my wife i've had a few arguments along
the way
let's focus on the good things not the
bad things and
early on in my life i was the first to
roll my eyes at this stuff
saying there this is goofy you can't
control your thoughts your mind goes
wherever it's going to go and that's it
well
with maturity and wisdom i've learned
that that's not true at all we truly can
control our thoughts and where we go
and and there is there is so much power
in in visualization
visualizing enzyme visualizing ourself
whether it be
me walking across the volcano me
speaking in front of a crowd
i would tell you interestingly enough
one of my one of my great fears was
public speaking it's something that i do
a lot now
and this is the most ironic thing about
it is
i would be nervous speaking front of a
crowd but put me on a wire in front of a
crowd which i started doing
these these corporations started renting
out arenas and i'll walk a wire 150 feet
up and i'll motivate you from that wire
for half an hour 45 minutes
i am way more calm leading up to getting
on that wire and speaking to them
than walking on the stage and speaking
with them there is something about the
psyche of
a calm and peacefulness about being on
that wire there's
it is sort of my again it's a safety net
as crazy as that sounds and it's just
the opposite of that
that is my safe haven so again i
encourage people
to to to think uh not overthink things
and control where you allow your mind to
go and again if we could capture that
i believe we could fulfill the greatest
dreams that we have whether it be
climbing mount everest whether it be
leaving that job that you're miserable
and fears holding you back from
from actually pursuing the dreams and
passions that you have whatever that
might be our minds are powerful tools
so so that's powerful what you just said
right there but uh
how many total hours would you say
you've spent on a wire or rope
well i know i've walked thousands of
miles on a wire certainly
i would tell you that i have probably
spent
uh at least a quarter of my life maybe a
little bit less than
a lot i mean i'll spend 68 hours a day
on the wire often five six days a week
you gotta be kidding me no i'm on the
wire a lot
let me let me get this straight did you
say four to six hours
a day six days a week on the wire yeah
six to eight hours a day often and
sometimes seven days a week
uh it is it is something that we it's
just like anything the more practice the
better you're going to get at it
and and with us the reality is it's life
and death
so it is even more important that we
spend that much time on the wire that
we're that familiar with it that
you know what i've learned is when i
become complacent is when it becomes
very very dangerous
and and those times where i go okay i
don't need to practice today i don't
need to rehearse
and then i'll get up on a wire between
two skyscrapers in pittsburgh
and all of a sudden it'll start pouring
down rain and i'll go oh my gosh i wish
i would rehearse more i wish i would
have been more prepared for this
i just did the math by the way if you
spend six hours a day on the wire on
average times six days a week
times 52 weeks in a year times 25 years
because you and i are the same age we're
three months apart or 41.
if you do that for 25 year average it's
47 000
hours on the wire does that sound about
right that's that's a lot of hours but
it does
i have spent a lot of my life on a wire
but just tells you you know whatever you
you hear the 10 000
hour uh rule you've taken a ten thousand
hour rule on a whole
a whole different level when are you
planning on stopping this whole thing
like when are you gonna stop walking on
wires i know you're
you're the the man that gave you a big
source your
you know inspiration and the level of
ambition that you have the fire that you
have
uh uh your grandpa carl 73 years old was
him
is there a time that you have where you
say i think i'm gonna you know stop at
such and such age you even think about
that yeah i do think about it and i
think about it
because of my great grandfather losing
his life and i even think about it when
my mom at 67 is getting on the wire
going mom
you shouldn't be doing this and my mom
will argue with me in fact
she told me specifically she pulled me
to the side one day and she said
nick i need to talk to you about
something and i i thought i was in
trouble this was only about a year ago
and i was like what what mom
what happened did i say something did i
do something wrong and she said
i want to make this clear on my 70th
birthday i want to do a walk with you
and uh and it was she was serious and
and again i thought i was in trouble i'm
like yes mom okay we'll figure it out
but that stresses me out just knowing
that my mom still wants to walk the wire
at 70. but like i said earlier
tell michael jordan to put the
basketball down because he retires from
the nba
he's not going to do it he still has a
full court i'm sure in every house that
he owns because that's
that's his passion it's what he loves
doing that's what inspires and motivates
him
so for us that's a that's a challenge
you know don't walk the wire
michael jordan's not risking his life
shooting a basketball we're risking our
life with our passion
yeah so i've tried to prepare myself
hopefully i've done a good job of
maybe 55 is what i've said uh that i
would i would retire from the wire
i don't i hope i'll be able to
accomplish that i don't know that i'll
be able to because i'm so passionate
about it
i will tell you that no matter what i
will always have a wire in my in my
backyard
and i'll always practice my mom's still
on the wire five days a week training
and uh for again she does one walk every
several years maybe
with me but the reality is she still is
on the wire every day because
it's it's her passion i think the over
under is you're going to go past 55. so
what is the next big one you want to do
so if you've done volcano you've done
times square chicago niagara falls what
what's the next one you're looking at
it is a challenge when you get to that
point in your career where
you have very little if any competition
and you're only pushing yourself
and driving yourself to go further and
go higher and define locations
um so at this point to be honest with
you a lot of them about parallels how do
i parallel
the grand canyon or niagara falls and
i'm working on a walk in the uk it's
something that i've wanted to do for a
long time again my great grandfather did
a walk over there by the
the london bridge and i want to do
something bigger bolder broader
but all to to pay respect and honor him
and then the other one
that gets a lot of people excited is i'm
i'm working on something
and a dream of mine to do a stunt it
won't be wire walking but in our
outer space actually ah okay let me get
this straight
outer space what why are walking outer
space no it wouldn't be a wire walk
there's there's a few other things that
i'm working on that are stunt related
uh that of course no one in the world
has ever done uh that would be pretty
awesome
and and make some incredible live tv and
truly what we do and what we've done for
200 years is inspire people that
nothing's impossible
and and that's why i continue to do what
i do that is that is truly what drives
me at this point
is to inspire when somebody says wow
when people come up to me after i get
off of a wire the size of a nickel 300
feet above between skyscrapers
and i've got teenagers coming up to me
and touching me just to see if i'm real
that's when i know i'm inspiring people
and that is really my passion and my
dream
no question you're doing that so you
know in sports you in boxing you
see a george foreman get knocked out by
muhammad ali nobody thought it was going
to happen he went into depression a
couple of years
you saw sugar ray leonard go against
roberto duran and
you know he beat him psychologically and
physically he was in depression for a
couple years
you see it happening in sports where
somebody goes to the finals or
world series or super bowl and it's a
very
you know traumatic loss public loss
sometimes they don't get over it
what did the 2017 event do to you
when your family was doing the uh uh the
you guys call it the pyramid walk i
believe with eight of you you can
highlight what that means and there was
an accident
and where you know most people fell
except for three of you i believe that
didn't fall and you were able to hold on
what did that do to you and how were you
able to recover from that single event
that happened to your family
yeah so we were training for about six
weeks here in
in florida in my backyard for that eight
person pyramid and
uh everything went pretty good we were
we were doing well we started two feet
went up ten feet
went up 15 feet and then decided we were
going to go up to the height to break
that world record
which was for this four layer eight
person pyramid 28 feet above the ground
and basically what it is is four people
standing on the wire two people on their
shoulders
and then a person on their shoulders and
then a person stacked on a fourth layer
on top of that so
the top person being my aunt was about
50 feet above the ground
at the apex of that pyramid and as we
made our way out in a rehearsal at full
height it was the second time we were
doing it up
at full height the next day we were
premiering it for guinness and in front
of a live audience
that was when my worst nightmare became
a reality we were walking our way out on
the wire
and uh not sure what happened lost our
balance
my five of my family members and friends
fell to the ground
and as you mentioned i caught the wire
my cousin caught the wire and one other
gentleman
stayed standing but the other five hit
the ground statistics say 30 percent
chance of living from a fall of that
height or greater without any safety
devices
my sister not only fell but she fell on
her head she broke every bone in her
face
she has 73 screws and plates in her face
alone at this point
was in a coma internal bleeding a lot of
broken bones my aunt a couple other guys
hurt pretty bad
and i remember sitting in the hospital
the day after that accident
and in the waiting room not knowing
whether people are going to be able to
walk anymore
not knowing whether my sister was going
to live we knew the other four were
were going to live but they weren't out
of the woods yet and
i remember sitting there and my dad
looking at me and saying hey you're
supposed to speak at emily arena in
tampa to a corporation tomorrow
he said what are you going to do and i
said dad i don't even know i i mean
never walked the wire again and it
wasn't fear at that point in any way it
was
it was the fact that i didn't want to
disrespect those that had fallen
and i thought you know are they how are
they going to look at me i certainly had
survivors guilt at that point i felt
horrible that i wasn't in a hospital
that i couldn't
trade places with any one of them and my
dad looked at me and he said well if
you're going to do it i'll be there for
you
you said i'll make sure your rigging is
safe and i'll make sure it goes off
without a hitch
i've got your back and and i get
goosebumps when i say that because here
his baby girl his only daughter
may not live but he supports his son to
the point where rather than being bitter
he says i'm there for you
i got your back and i remember i
remember going you know what
that thinking back to my great
grandfather the legacy him him
going back to the wire the day after
that accident and saying
you're right this is what our family
does i said but i'm going to take it a
step further
i'm going gonna go visit the other four
that are in the hospital and talk to the
other two the other two that stayed and
caught the wire
couldn't talk to my sister at that point
and get their blessing and i did that i
made the rounds through the hospital
and said what is your opinion every one
of them looked at me and said
you have to do it get back on the wire
so i did i got back on the wire the next
day
i performed in fact for the next five
weeks straight with only four days off
all the while my sister's still in the
hospital and in the process of
recovering at that point
and after that five weeks i took six
weeks off and then we headed to new york
city where i was headlining on a new
show
where we were going to perform the
seven-person pyramid so very similar to
that pyramid
mat in fact uh peripherally the same as
as that eight-person pyramid for me so
uh we started training and i started
visualizing that that pyramid falling in
front of me on the wire
and after about a week of that i started
to physically tremble on the wire
something i'd never experienced in my
life in fact
the emotion of fear i didn't even think
existed in my dna
certainly for walking the wire and i
remember going through that process
and and after a week of that going to my
wife and saying
do you do you know what's going on in
the pyramid are you watching this and
she goes yeah i said well who's shaking
and the reason i ask that is as the
leader of that pyramid for
for years i've done it thousands of
times i would there's always somebody
who has jitters early on
and when they shake you feel them you're
all connected together and she looked at
me she said what do you mean
i was like who's shaking she goes it's
you and i thought there's no way
it can't be me i i was still denying the
fact that i was dealing with fear at
that point
and uh i said uh well i'm gonna get back
in the wire and see if i can work
through this couple days later one of my
guys in my troop who's been with me my
whole life grabs me
literally grabs me after rehearsal and
shakes me and he goes what the hell is
wrong with you
i was like what do you mean what's wrong
with me thinking that they didn't know
what was going on
they can't see me they're all in front
of me or on top and he says
you're shaking like crazy what is going
on with you this isn't the nic wallenda
that we've all
looked up to that that drives us to
greatness this is not the guy who we've
respected
and at that point what happened was hey
i had to admit that i was fearful
but at that point i was dealing with
shame the fact that here i
am the the you know the greatest wire
walker of our generation
i'm fearless and i'm not fearless and
people are realizing this
and people are recognizing this and at
that point
i had to actually back up further and
deal with the pride that led to shame
the pride that i was too good to be
fearful deal with the shame and then dig
down to the root of what fear actually
was
and then then work through that fear it
got to the point where i told my wife
one evening i said i'm done i'm not
getting back on the wire ever again i'm
done and i remember that conversation
like it was
right now and my wife looked at me now
mind you my wife comes from eight
generations of circus on one side
seven of the o of the other she has two
guinness world records herself she's an
amazing aerialist and daredevil
and and she supports me because of that
and that's how she can understand
my passion for doing these things and
she looked at me and she said
for 200 years your family have lived by
the words never give up
the show must go on that's the way
you've lived you do what you do
all the time you're inspiring people
that nothing's impossible and you're
gonna give up because of something in
your head
she goes nah that's not you you're not
gonna give up and i remember sitting
back feeling defeated literally
sitting back in the couch and tears
rolling down my face like i'm defeated
i changed two laws in two countries i
walked across some of the craziest
places in the world without safety
devices
risking my life and this small
four-letter word
fear is is going to ruin the rest of my
career
and possibly my life and i started going
down this route of
depression and as i started going down
that that path which many people do
i remember um just sitting there i
always reflect on my great grandfather
and his
book and his stories that i've been told
and the videos i've watched and
the tapes that i've listened to and i
thought you know what this isn't what my
family does i'm not going to go down
this path
and my mind was deep it was in the
gutter at that point i was in the valley
and i remember thinking you know what
everything my great-grandfather did
he was able to overcome and he was able
to prove that the impossible was
possible
and even though this feels impossible
i'm going to overcome it and when i
overcome it i'm going to write about it
i'm going to tell the story and i'm
going to use this so other people that
are dealing with fear
don't have to go so down deep into that
valley like i did and don't have to go
into that deep depression
and that's when i set off on this
journey of of going
and really it was it was about stepping
out and going
okay how were you raised what were you
taught and and what are you doing
differently now
and and it really came down to the power
of the mind and where i allowed my mind
to go and controlling those thoughts and
and drowning out that negativity and
continuing to focus on positive rather
than thinking
you're gonna fall while you're holding
this pyramid i would think you've held
it more than anyone in the world
successfully thousands of times you've
held this pyramid one accident and
you're gonna focus on the one not the
thousands
and i started just telling myself that
and working through this process and
and again with the help of psychologists
and psychiatrists and spending time with
people
that really could teach me to to
re-learn
who i was and re-learn how i do and have
done what i do
you know the question i have for you is
obviously one i can tell affirmations is
a big part of your life it sounds like
affirmation is a big part of your life
when you were walking across chicago at
the end you said in the middle of it you
said so blessed for these opportunities
and then at the end you said god is so
good and praise you god thank you jesus
i mean
you're you're talking and this is a form
of affirmation
so blessed for these opportunities while
you're walking on the wire god is so
good who says that
while they're doing like imagine
somebody's playing basketball saying god
thank you so much for allowing me to
make the last shot
or you know shoot the last shot or thank
you so much for giving me the
opportunity to build a business
and raise millions of dollars and you
know try to take it to the next level
how much of a role does faith
play in your life how much of it is
training how much of it is mental and
emotional toughness what would you say
i would say it is is probably split into
thirds
evenly i mean my training is important
the mental aspect is is part of the the
training is the mental training as well
the physical training
is what lines up the mental training and
preparation
and then my faith plays a key role in
just who i am and the truth is
i am so grateful i i see it as surreal i
have been able to do things
again niagara falls the process of
getting permission no one in the world
will likely ever do that again 100 years
ago there was a guy named charles blonde
who walked
and people say over niagara falls but he
walked a
third of a mile down from the falls uh
just over the river he never walked over
the precipice of niagara falls so i know
that i'm in positions
where no one in the world will ever be
these natural wonders are breathtaking
that i'm able to walk over and i do see
it as an amazing opportunity
a this is me living my dream you know it
is like somebody
who wants to play in the nfl who gets
drafted into the nfl and saying
thank you god this has been my dream my
entire life
and my dream is coming true every time i
get on that wire
that's the way i see it this is my dream
and especially in these bigger walks
which are the televised ones
there's a lot of them where of course
i'm very thankful but it's not as
meaningful as what the process of
changing two laws in two countries and
and going through all of that to get
permission then finally achieving that
dream which
was seemingly impossible not because of
the the defeat
itself because of the permitting process
of it again i am extremely grateful for
those opportunities and i and i don't
take it lightly and i consider myself
extremely blessed i look at my family i
look at our our industry as a whole one
of my
passions and dreams is to revitalize the
circus and i believe that everything
comes in full circle and that is
something that i've challenged myself
with is
how do we reinvent the circus it is one
of the oldest forms the more the purest
forms of family entertainment
that inspires people people clearly love
it when i walked over the grand canyon
23 million people watched live in the us
alone
breaking rating records on the biggest
network in the world people love what we
do in the circus
but the reality is i don't think that
they quite understand it and now i've
had the platform an opportunity to
present it to them in a whole new
spotlight
with the dream of getting them to come
to the circus and see this amazing stuff
so i have set that goal on myself the
last chapter i talk about it it's it's
it's about that fear of feathers my
great-grandfather said in the circus one
day you eat the chicken the next day you
eat the feathers
well i've had that fear and i've had
that fear to take on this challenge of
reinventing the circus
but it is something that i'm passionate
about and i'm hoping once we in fact i
was well on the pathway when we got hit
with this virus
and actually turned a little bit because
i'm all about reinventing the wheel
and uh ended up creating this awesome
drive-in thrill show that we've been
touring with
where i've called all of my daredevil
friends over 27 guinness world records
held by
just the performers on this show that's
touring and
normally we're never able to work
together we see each other at televised
events etc and we celebrate together
we're never able to perform together
well because of this virus none of us
have contracts entertainment live
entertainment's dead
so i was able to call all my friends up
and say let's go put on
this incredible show and let's bring it
to people's backyards where they can
drive in their car
turn into our radio station i'll
motivate them from the wire you can
shoot out of a cannon and you can do a
double backflip on your motorcycle and
and we can inspire these people during a
time where it's very hard to be inspired
you know there's something very
attractive about your personality by the
way
a book that have you ever read the book
blue ocean strategy or no
i have not okay i think blue ocean
strategy is a great book for you because
it's it's sold over four and a half
million copies uh it's
it's about how to create a
unique how to disrupt an industry
and do something that's never been done
before gives you the exact formula in it
and the main story that the consultants
and the author talk about
is circus circus soleil so if you've
never read blue ocean strategy
it's a phenomenal book for somebody like
you since you're saying you want to
reinvent the
industry but yeah i got i got a
technical question for you i'm curious
to know what you're going to say about
this one here
you know sometimes when you're uh
winning and for some it comes in
different levels right oh you start
making more money than your mom and dad
was like oh i'm making more money with
my mom my mom and dad i'm
i mean hey mom you don't tell me what to
do dad you don't tell me what to do do
you know your son is making a quarter
million dollar income
and and maybe sometimes you're uh uh
running a business and you become the
best in your office in sales or you're
running the best
business local community or you're in
sports and you start winning and you're
getting a lot of accolades and people
are telling how amazing you are
here's a guy that no matter where you go
you said kids are touching you to see if
you're real you walked across a volcano
you know times square chicago niagara
falls
how do you prevent yourself from being
cocky
yeah that's a great question i would
tell you my wife does a great job at
preventing me from being cocky
she always keeps me in check but you
know what i was raised to always be
humble and kind no matter what never
forget where i came from i was also
raised
in in a world where you know i told my
children all along and
my father used to always tell me the
person who's sweeping the floor might be
running the company
next time you meet him and that's the
reality and i think that everybody
deserves everybody's created equally all
of us are on
a level playing field in a level
platform we all have the same
opportunities and and
and i think what keeps me humble is to
continue to reach down to those people
and say look i made it up here now it's
your turn if i can do it on a wire then
you can do it in your business and your
corporation
i don't care i've told my kids when i
raised them i don't care if you work at
mcdonald's
or if you work at for the pentagon or if
you're the president of the united
states
you do it to the best of your ability
you work as hard as you possibly can
and you make your boss's job as easy as
possible and you will eventually have
his job
and because of that they are extremely
confident in life
not bold not cocky not arrogant but
extremely responsible in fact i couldn't
be more proud of my 22 year old marine
who's serving our country
he didn't have to do that dad has money
dad could have sent me to college and
done
he could have taken on businesses that
i've started locally and he could have
done great that way
but he chose on his own to serve our
country for four years before he moved
on to do that stuff
19 year old in the army i get goosebumps
why are my children in the military
they were raised to respect our nation
and uh
and they do so again out of choice it
was their decision it wasn't though
as though they didn't have any choice it
wasn't as though they didn't have other
opportunity but they literally said
you know what we want to serve our
nation and uh and
to me uh the most rewarding thing a job
opportunity uh i've had in my life is
raising children
and there's nothing more rewarding than
seeing the fruits of what you've worked
so hard on
well i got to tell you man my hat's off
to you uh
for anybody that's watching this if
there's ever been a time where you want
to read a book
on fear i mean if there's ever been a
time where you want to get good at
controlling your emotions
your imagination how to overcome fear
how to deal with anxiety and panic
attacks
today's the time we're going to put the
link below to
uh nick's book that just came out you'll
be one of the first people that ever
orders it
the link will be below facing fear
by nick wolenda with don yager
uh nick i've had a blast uh studying
about your family
i've had a blast watching a bunch of
your videos which is fascinating
and i've really enjoyed talking to you i
i felt more the depth of your character
your family's character
and i think it's something a lot of
people can use as a source of
inspiration so having said that
thank you so much for making the time
for being a guest on valuetainment
thanks so much for having me on it was
an honor
appreciate you what a great time to be
studying this whole mental toughness and
emotional toughness mindset especially
coming from somebody
that walks on wires across you know
times square or you know niagara falls
or a volcano
where do you have to go mentally to do
that i was fascinated by the interview
be curious to know what you took away
from it
please comment below your thoughts and
if you want to watch
more things having to do with the
mindset of somebody that's able to
compete at that level i did an interview
with tim grover
who was a trainer to michael jordan he
was in the last dance
he was a trainer to kobe bryant and
dwyane wade and many others
if you've never watched this interview i
just want to prepare you
i think we counted a hundred f-bombs he
drops the entire interview
but he will give you a certain way of
thinking that got him to write this book
called relentless that
most athletes have read if you've never
watched that interview before click over
here
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye you